what's up everybody welcome back to LED
live it seems like we're racing towards
the end of the world there's so many
movies that talk about it the apocalypse
and raptures but when it comes to
Hollywood doctrine are they leaving the
truth behind find out on this episode of
LED live hey guys we'd like to thank our
patreon donors without you we could not
have this show and if you would like to
support this show you can become a
patron by going to our patreon channel
and you get a lot of cool perks you get
behind-the-scenes access you get early
access you get some cool t-shirts some
of the other people don't get to get
also we do have t-shirts that anyone can
get including this one that Scottie has
on and this one that's Keith as on so we
want to jump into this have you guys
ever seen a movie about the end of the
world yep 1012 yeah 2012 was a big one
about the calendar and all that right
well I looked up apocalyptic movies and
there's just so many they can't even fit
on a screen and some of them you know
you're kind of surprised about like lego
movies on here so yes I mean there's
kids movies you think about it there's a
lot of movies where the scenario is
about the end of the world I remember we
were looking into an animated movie
called Croods which is or the Croods
it's about a family of cavemen or
whatever but that was the same thing
they found out that there was an end of
the world it just comes up so many times
in so many different ways there's the
end of the world coming and how what can
we do to stop it
mm-hmm as Christians should we want to
stop the end of the world
nope yeah you know I mean all the
superhero movies that's literally what
it's about is stopping the end of the
world so to say and preserving life
which sounds like a really good thing
right yeah we want to preserve life but
if you look at it from a biblical
perspective like yes God is coming to
destroy the wicked
there will be an end for those that
don't choose god yeah God never chose to
destroy a life unless it was corrupt in
some way I mean the days of Noah every
thought of their mind was evil
continually and he still said Noah
preached these people for a hundred
years while you're building the ark and
and I'm giving them away they can get on
that Ark but it's up to them you know so
we got all these movies it's just weird
that Hollywood keeps pushing this you
know does Hollywood know something that
we don't know I mean what is the thing
what is like the attraction to
apocalyptic movies why are there so many
more I mean it's not it's not like a new
new concept I mean we had like Mad Max
in the 80s and stuff but it seems like
every movie that comes out is based on
the end of the world I think it's not
just pop culture I mean you look at all
the different like religions they kind
of knows something Crazy's gonna happen
in the future right they're all waiting
for some huge castra catastrophic event
to happen if you look at the scientific
world they're looking at the world going
hey we see an expiration date on this
thing I mean you know whether you're on
the global warming train or the other
side of the fence everyone's kind of
points in to the end of this thing that
that we know of is life or life as as
this planets concerned so I think
Hollywood's probably picking up on that
yeah people are just scared of that so
they're capitalizing on it yeah that we
know there's like predictive programming
our audience probably knows about that
and we know that Satan the enemy is like
using Hollywood to try and you know mold
the world could it be could there be
something about it like is are they
training us to you know do I don't know
how to say this are they preparing us
for something but getting us to be on
the opposite side I mean this is all
about stopping the end you know fighting
those aliens that are coming Jesus is an
alien you know he's coming he's not just
to clarify not an extraterrestrial he's
he's an alien he's not from this earth
he's coming down and we're
where there's all these movies that are
like we're gonna fight this right right
and we know that revelation 20 talks
about that there's gonna be a battle of
all the wicked people of the earth that
are fighting against the coming of the
Lord you know right it's interesting
that there's always movies that are
based on that I looked up rapture just
singled out rapture movies and a lot of
them are Christian movies but there are
some that aren't Christian rapture
Palooza you ever heard of that one
barbecued my son I panicked I laser beam
dump I beam Jesus I'm so sorry yeah
pretty messed up
I mean rapture Palooza was really just
making fun of the people that were left
here and so you know what life would be
like from their perspective well
everybody else is gone the millennium
there yeah they're really a bunch of
people who don't really care about God
or anything like this so as all these
plagues are being dumped out they're
like whatever so the blood is running
wild in the streets there's locusts
everywhere who cares you know and
they're just dealing with the life as
it's coming up them well I'm so scared I
know
yeah rapture Palooza you know Palooza is
usually like a party we're like we're
going to that big concert you know
Lollapalooza rapture Palooza it's like
all the Christians are going like whoo
it's party time but it's like oh it's
raining blood again or the look I had to
fight the locusts on my way to work and
all this stuff yeah but but what they're
teaching is that there's gonna be a time
period where the Christians are gonna be
gone and there's gonna be some amount of
time where there's people who weren't
taken and they're having to go through
these plagues that's a very popular
teaching that there's going to be a time
period where the Christians are taken
but there's some time during this plague
thing it's called the tribulation are
you guys do you believe that are you
aware that that there's what do you
think well I think the Bible is very
clear about teaching there will be a
time that is like none other on the face
of the planet you know and it's like
these people will experience this like
sort of just end of the world scenario
I think the discrepancy between what
some some people believe is like when
that time is and where all those people
are and who's involved and who's
involved and who experiences that and
who doesn't experience that so my
knowledge of what the rapture is is that
there will be a group of people that
well they're just taken to heaven and so
all the other people that are
experiencing these terrible things on
earth they didn't go to heaven so
they're experienced in that right so
there's there's three views to put in a
show there's the pre-tribulation rapture
which means that there's the the
teaching or the theory is that there's a
seven years of tribulation I don't know
that there's we actually did a show on
Messiah where Keith talked about the
70th week of Daniel and how it's been
skewed into saying that this 70th week
was detached from the 69th week which
makes it no longer 70 weeks now it's
like two hundred thousand weeks but the
70th week which is seven years it's not
at the end of time somewhere that's a
seven year tribulation so that's where
they get the idea but the there's a
pre-trib rapture which means the church
is going to be taken up before that so
then all the wicked people are here for
seven years on earth then some people
say no it's mid-trib which means
three-and-a-half years into that
seven-year tribulation the Christians
are raptured up right before the
Antichrist enforces the mark of the
beast
so either way Christians aren't going to
be here for the mark of the beast' issue
Wow and and then there's another
teaching that says poster which means it
happens all after all this stuff happens
then we go up do they have a reason as
to why then what's the point of the
Antichrist if the Christians are already
gone well there's gonna be tribulation
Saints so this is like pre hell why I
guess it's like the final test like if
you didn't accept me now you have this
choice to die instead of taking the mark
of the beast and you can still be
redeemed so it's like one last little
thing but it's very difficult yeah okay
so there's been a lot of these movies in
the 70s there was one called a thief in
the night is anybody here
remember this okay
thief in the night are you familiar with
a scripture that this is based off oh
yeah okay well we're gonna get into that
but I just want to make sure you you
realize that this is from 1972 and
here's the synopsis a story of patty a
young woman caught up and living for the
present with a little concern for the
future she meets and marries a young man
and her life seems great until one
moment she wakes up to find her husband
gone and the radio reporting millions of
people have mysteriously disappeared as
dramatic earth-shaking events begin to
unfold around her patty realizes she is
living in the end times spoken of the
biblical prophecy Adventure and suspense
build to thought-provoking climax in
this powerful gripping film so the
verses that they're getting this from a
thief of the night so this movie you
heard what I said right she woke up her
husband's gone but she's still here so
they're getting it from that they're
building this whole theology this whole
movie storyline off this one verse or
two verses they say a thief in the night
so second Peter 3:10 says but the day of
the Lord will come as a thief in the
night in the which the heavens shall
pass away with a great noise and the
elements shall melt with fervent heat
the earth also and the works that are
therein shall be burned up all right so
what are you seeing that doesn't line up
with what this movie says well the movie
says he's coming like a thief in the
night
but she's left behind during this but
this verse look at the look at the last
part of this so it's loud and stuff
burned up and Stein vis over at that
point total destruction yeah it says in
the which so as a thief in the night in
the which the heavens shall pass away
with a great noise they'll melt for me
the other thing is if you if you read
the verse very closely the thief in the
night part is not so much describing the
Lord as it is in the day hmm
so the day is a surprise right not God
coming being a surprise which one would
be like the subtle difference between
those two things the the subtle
difference between those two things is
if a day is coming as a thief in the
night a day coming being a surprise is
that you don't know when that day is
coming Jesus coming being a surprise
gives the idea that he's all of a sudden
just gonna show up and you know nobody's
gonna notice yeah nobody's gonna notice
yeah but that's not the description of
when Jesus comes so there is one other
verse in case somebody says no you're
reading the wrong verse because that's
that's what seems to happen whenever you
talk about this is that people say no
you keep bringing up the verses about
the second coming you're not bringing up
the pre-tribulation rapture verse I'm
like well which one is it cuz all these
verses it the name of the movies thief
in the night so the next one is first
Thessalonians five two three three you
want to read that candy sure for
yourselves know perfectly that the day
of the Lord so cometh as a thief in the
night be from the night for when they
shall say peace and safety then sudden
destruction cometh upon them as travail
upon a woman with child and they shall
not escape well so again we see that
when this thief in the night thing
happens there is sudden destruction okay
not three years later in your son
destruction seven years later the son
destruction so maybe people say well
that movies wrong you know but this
movie was teaching a pre-tribulation
rapture theory and that was the name of
the movie based on the scripture so then
there was a there's been another movie
from a Christian company I think there's
pure flix called in the blink of an eye
you know a verse that's based off oh
you're gonna change just think the first
Corinthians 15 I think yeah
first Corinthians 15:51 through 53 you
want to read that linky behold I show
you a mystery we shall not all sleep but
we should all be changed
in a moment in the twinkling of an eye
at the last Trump for the trumpet shall
sound and the dead shall be raised
incorruptible and we shall be changed
for this corruptible must put on
incorruption and this mortal must put on
immortality
so we see that there's coming a time
that we are going to be changed and
people say yeah that's it that's the
that's the rapture but there's something
interesting that people don't really pay
attention to and you see it's about this
trumpet sound he's coming with this
trumpet sound and with a loud voice and
the dead in Christ are going to rise but
what does it say about this trumpet
specifically a descriptive term about
this trumpet last one it's the last one
if you know other trumpets after that
yeah the last is the last right so what
happens in the book of Revelation when
the plagues re-import up the world well
there's like there's such things that
come after every time a plague is poured
out there's a sound of a trumpet that's
right
so these people are teaching that the
rapture happens before the plagues
that's before the tribulation but if
there's seven trumpets and the return of
Christ and this change happens at the
last trumpet that's either the seventh
trumpet or you know something after that
it's got to be the last so that's you
know and then you can there's a parallel
to this this verse that talks about
being changed in a moment when Clara
dies first Corinthians 15:52 is that the
one we just read yeah okay so here's
another one first Thessalonians 4:16
through 17 and it says for the Lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of the Archangel
and with the Trump of God and the dead
in Christ shall rise first then we which
are alive and remain shall be caught up
together with them in the clouds to meet
the lord in the air and so shall we ever
be with the Lord I thought we're already
left Waymon according to the rapture
yeah wouldn't we have left so who are
the ones who will caught up in the air
mmm that's a good point
hmm yeah because I right here I
highlighted two things just to make sure
people know this is a parallel verse
this isn't like well one is about this
event there's another one about this is
the same thing because people say no the
Trump of God is different than the last
Trump this is the same event it's
talking about the last trumpet and a
Trump is gonna sound and the dead in
Christ will rise
there's not another time when these
trumpets sound in the dead in Christ
rise right how many resurrections of the
righteous are they right one one that
God says you know do you who sleep in
the dust rise
yeah and I was at the last trumpet the
Trump of God so then there's a movie I
don't know who put this out for this as
looks like a older one 1998 called into
the harvest and does anybody can anybody
think of a verse that this is about well
we are called to be Reapers of the
harvest right were God's workers in the
field which is the earth and he's coming
to collect the harvest when he comes
yeah that was your friend too yeah so
Jesus told a parable about the wheat and
the tares right yeah let's see what
Jesus said about the end of the world
and how this rapture event would happen
he says the kingdom of heaven is likened
unto a man which sowed good seed in his
field but while men slept his enemy came
and sowed tares among the wheat and went
in his way or went his way but when the
blade was sprout sprung up and brought
forth fruit then appeared the tares also
so the servants of the householder came
and said unto Him Serge it's now just
stop it's not thou sow good seed in the
field from whence then hath it tares he
said unto them an enemy has done this
the servants said unto Him wilt thou
then that we go and gather them up but
he said nay lest while ye
gather up the tares ye root up also the
wheat with them let both grow together
until the harvest and in the time of the
harvest I will say to the Reapers gather
ye together first the tares and bind
them into bundles to burn them but
gather the wheat into my barn what do
you guys see in here that seems to not
line up with what these movies are
saying well the rapture says that they
will pick up a good one first you know
what's this thing what's this one say
this one say like they will let the good
and the bad grow together and then in
the end the good one will go but it even
mentioned you said that they gather the
good ones first
this actually mentions somebody being
gathered first bit tears the tears are
gathered first so burn them I mean if
we're gonna have anybody gathered first
this verse tells us and it says let them
both grow together till win no hard
without the harvest okay so this is a
parable but Jesus spoke plain words to
his disciples he said he that soweth the
good seed is of the son of man the field
is the world so he's explaining what
these parables mean the field is the
world the good seed are the children of
the kingdom but the tares are the
children of the wicked one the enemy
that sowed them is the devil the harvest
is the end of the world he said let them
grow together till the harvest he says
the harvest is the end of the world does
that mean the end of the world before
seven years of more Earth or is it the
end of the world the Reapers are the
Angels as therefore the tares are
gathered and burned in the fire so shall
I be in the end of this world the Son of
man shall send forth his angels and they
shall gather out of his kingdom all the
things that offend see that he's
gathering the ones that offend first and
then which do iniquity and shall cast
them into a furnace of fire there shall
be wailing and gnashing of teeth then
shall the righteous shine forth as the
Sun in the kingdom of their father who
hath who hath ears let him hear you know
it just clicked for me that Jesus was
describing the great controversy here to
his disciples how awesome is that
because you have this battle but
between the the enemy and the owner of
the of the field you know this conflict
between God and Satan then you have the
Angels the whole world is keeping watch
over and what is the field represent the
world like this this war that's going on
here and we have both the the wheat and
the tares going together and there's a
dialogue in heaven like okay like should
we what should we do and God just like
wait you know let's let's let things
play out that's that's pretty amazing
that Jesus was just laying it all out
I just wow that is awesome you know it's
such a amazing illustrator and his
stories so here I've highlighted you
know so let them grow together until the
end of the harvest and our artists in
the world gather them first to burn them
and this says gather them first the burn
them and it says gather the wheat into
my barn then let the righteous shine
forth as a son so this is saying that
he's gonna gather the wicked first but
he's gonna like leave the righteous
right leave them alive not burn them but
leave them so that makes me think of
another movie Left Behind with Nicolas
Cage
so I mean should we be trust in
Hollywood for good theology yeah now I
I've never seen this film series I
remember when it came out and when
people read the books and things like
that
but I didn't I wasn't in that space can
you give me like a sent out this so the
synopsis is the entire planet is thrown
into mayhem when millions of people
disappear without a trace all that
remains are their clothes and belongings
unmanned vehicles crashed and planes
fall from the sky overwhelming emergency
forces and and causing massive gridlock
riots and chaos airline pilot ray steel
or Nicolas Cage struggles to save the
lives of the passengers who remain on
his flight while his daughter races to
find her brother and mother both of whom
have disappeared I want to mention this
because what is the consummation of
every Christians life the hopefulness
that we have something better coming
right now doesn't it just make sense
that God would make this just grand
glorious finale ending
not this this little or even to cause
more chaos
yeah I dunno it just seems like like
like this what what a what a sort of a
wah wah wah I'm sorry your life was
terrible down there and then this
happens right yeah rather than like this
glorious thing that happens in the sky
and Jesus is coming and we see the king
sitting in there I mean think about
there's a lot of details here that are
that are in the like little minor things
where you know as he's speaking to to
the accusers Jesus speaking to his
accusers any same you're gonna see the
Son of man sitting on the right hand of
God you know coming like you know like
just where I was going as a revelation
1:7 behold he's coming with clouds and
every eye will see him even those who
pierced him and all the tribes of the
earth will mourn because of him so so
how do those because does it pierced him
burn dead how do they probably gonna see
it him what a question for those who
believe in the rapture do they also
believe in the grand second coming of
Jesus yeah cuz they'll say all these
verses you keep bringing up are the
second coming not the rapture this is
two separate people come back or okay so
the people who see Jesus coming are the
ones that are left so everyone is
already in heaven yeah also it's the
wicked people and those tribulation
Saints who were left behind but they've
made a choice that doesn't make any
sense because Jesus says I come with the
reward in my hands with me so if he's
rewarding only the wicked right for
their deeds and are some people who left
behind who refused the mark of the beast
and they get a second chance they get a
second chance but where's the Bible
evidence for that there's people that
are in the grades that do they are they
waiting to raise with the tribulation
Saints where do they go at the first
group I love how we're trying to figure
this out oh yeah I'm trying to wrap my
head around the logic of that
the verses they give definitely say that
the dead in Christ will rise so it has
to be a pre-tribulation rapture and the
dead are rising up along with them but
then seven years later Christ returns
the wicked are slain and those
tribulation Saints get to go up and then
they're dead and so I said how many how
many resurrections are there theories at
some point how many righteous
resurrections are there there's only one
and that's where I can't say anybody
could buy into this but the things that
I hear is that the event is a very loud
event and there you know is you know the
elements breaking apart and you know
destruction that's a very dramatic scene
not a quiet scene but the thing you
brought up made me think about it it
says every eye will see him like I'm
coming and everyone's gonna see him but
if you go up seven years before he comes
then you're not gonna see this amazing
event I mean you might be there with
them but it's it's like we're looking
forward to this amazing thing but if you
go up before the seven you know but it's
not amazing I mean you just think about
how many churches you've been in with
the stained glass on the back of the
church with this picture of Jesus of the
second coming or something behind them
right I mean when you die that's your
hope that that's what you're gonna see
in the clouds and all of a sudden you're
like like oh wait I'm here you know like
like to me it just makes a lot more
sense that that God is gonna end this
finale with him coming in the clouds and
it's like you know everyone everyone at
that point is gonna realize you know
whose God is the people that are living
do you know they're gonna see him coming
into clouds and you know another thing
we're not the only ones human beings
aren't the only ones praising God
so is nature the Buddhists the disciples
said even the wind and the waves obey
Him every scripture we've read there's
some that the elements are reacting or
responding to God's presence with the
rapture just the humans that are
are going up so I think you know the
focus is on that but now this is a
worldwide even an element wide thing
when when the creator comes and shows
himself everyone everything responds
yeah and and from what I read it says
that the wicked will be consumed by the
brightness of his coming when he comes
the wicked every slain and it says that
we are changed meaning we can withstand
his presence and be caught up together
to meet him in the air and and it's a
good thing that we're up and their slain
because the elements melt with fervent
heat I mean it's it says that it's gonna
be like an oven yeah one thing that I
think is really twisted Satan is the
biggest a Caesar deceiver of all time he
can twist anything and he just wants
everyone's doctrine to be totally
twisted to the point where people say I
don't want to be left behind the movie
says don't be left behind the song says
you know that you've been left behind
and it's in a sane in a bad light but
let's look at this in Matthew 24 37
through 40 it says but as the days of
Noah were so shall also the coming of
the Son of Man be for as in the days
that were before the flood they were
eating and drinking marrying and giving
in marriage until the day that Noah
entered into the ark and knew not until
the flood came and took them all away so
shall also the coming of the Son of man
be then shall two be in the field one
shall be taken in the other left so the
scenario that this film is based off of
is saying there's two guys in the field
once taken to heaven no one's left but
what we've already read is that the
wicked are gathered first and the
righteous are left shining forth like
the Sun you know they're gathered in as
a barn or whatever and what I think is
interesting is that it says the flood
came in took them all away
you hear this word right what what was
the taking was it Noah in the ark or was
it the flood you know it was the
destruction that took right so it says
so shall also the coming this son of man
be
his come he's gonna be just like this
taking right his coming is gonna be just
like
those that were took away by the
floodwaters and it says one will be
taken does that mean he's taken up or
does that mean he's taken by the center
extent yeah that's actually an
interesting thing I've never actually
looked at that verse as that as meaning
that but if you put it in that kind of
context then yeah just because you're
taking something doesn't necessarily
mean taking it you can take someone's
life then they cease to exist there's
other verses that support that idea I
don't know if you're going to go over
them yeah so a parallel to this verse
says basically the same thing
Luke 17 34 to 37 I have it here I tell
you in that night there shall be two men
in one bed
the one shall be taken and the other
shall be left two women shall be
grinding together the one shall be taken
and the other left two men shall be in
field the one shall be taken and the
other left and they answer it and say
unto Him where Lord and he said unto
them wheresoever the body the body is
theater will be the Eagles be gathered
together okay what were they saying
where Lord would that mean where what
we're gonna take a your tea yeah where
are they taking any answers the Eagles
will be gathered together where the body
is the dead body is that's where the
Eagles would be able together this isn't
describing people flying with the Eagles
because it says in Matthew 24 about the
same event for wheresoever the carcass
is there will the eagle's be gathered
together these are carnivorous Birds
eating the corpses of those and this is
the same event right here this is notice
what it says this is all describing the
coming of the Lord with these in the
secret chambers don't look he's coming
like lightning right after it says
wherefore the carcass is there will the
eagle's be gathered together it says
immediately after the tribulation of
those days the Sun will be darkened the
moon will not give her light the stars
will fall from heaven the powers of
heaven will be shaken and then shall
appear the sign of the Son of man in
heaven and then show the tribes of earth
mourn and they shall see the Son of man
coming in clouds of heaven
with power and great glory and shall
send His angels with a great sound of a
trumpet and they will gather together
his elect didn't we already hear about
this trumpet and the gathering and they
say that that happens before seven years
but right here it says immediately after
the tribulation of those days you can't
get more clear than this and it's
repeated over and over and over again
that's really interesting that you know
one will be taken and you know their
flesh will be eaten like that's it
that's interesting because I have heard
that and I did always envision that one
would you know be gone but not not
necessarily given the rapture way but
just that one would be the word for the
clouds yeah and the other one would be
like oh if I'm not floating then all of
a sudden I'm yeah I'm not going there
yeah but that's interesting to look at
the concept like that
to think this Satan you know he's just
twist everything dude you don't want to
be left behind
you know this is this is okay I think I
might need a second so that means in
that case you do want to be left behind
because you don't want to be that dead
carcass you don't want to be the first
ones cuz they're the ones that are
gathered to be right and and here's also
something else that that is sort of
alarming to me is it's like it kind of
almost takes the the fear off of well
I'm not going to experience that that
whole end of the thing cuz I'm on my way
I'm going up to heaven or whatever like
this so that doesn't really apply to me
yeah
whereas this time it's a time of testing
it's a time that that God is literally
saying look the gospel works and Satan's
gonna throw everything and the handbag
at these people to try and prove his
point and God saying you can test him
they're still not gonna choose you so I
think that takes the pressure off of
this point where people are just like
well whatever like I'm not gonna be
going through that test no we're all
going through that test I don't see a
lot of examples where does people were
I'm actually not thinking about any on
the top of my head from terrible
situations you have the example of Jeb
you know Satan threw everything out and
you have the example of Shadrach Meshach
and Abednego you know they went through
the fire you have the example of the
children of Israel and the plagues that
fell on Egypt they weren't removed from
Egypt they were preserved through the
plagues right the first three if I
remember right they experienced along
with the Egyptians and then the next
ones they were still in Egypt but they
were shielded so I kind of get the
psychological reason for not wanting to
go all that stuff I mean that makes
sense
I get that nobody looks forward to bad
things but that also kind of tends to
you know limit the power of God in our
minds and say well just because you're
here doesn't mean you're experiencing
those things mm-hmm God is a Sun and
shield as a Psalm 84 11 it says that the
Lord God is a Sun and a shield and it
says no good thing will he withhold from
those who live up rightly I think it is
or righteously let listen to this 2nd
Thessalonians 2:8 and 9 okay we've used
this verse on this show like tons of
times right listen to this 2nd
Thessalonians 2:8 and then shall the
wicked be revealed whom the Lord shall
consume with the spirit of his mouth and
shall destroy with the brightness of his
coming ok even who him whose coming is
after the working with all power and
signs and lying wonders and with all
deceivableness and all unrighteousness
in them that perish because they
received not a love of the truth truth
because that they might be saved so to
me those verses are pretty clear that
there is a time that deception is going
to come to people that they literally
weren't
in love with the truth and their
deceived it isn't just like oh the
wicked they're already deceived they're
already whatever no this is like this is
like an experience that's happening to
to literally people God's people if you
would if you're not standing on the very
foundation of truth well dentists say
that he turns them over to a strong
delusion or something like that right it
does and and it says and for this cause
starting with verse 11 God shall send
them a strong delusion that they should
believe the lie and that they all might
be damned who believed not the truth but
had pleasure in unrighteousness so
that's where I when I want to discuss
these types of things with people it
gets to the point where they're just
like well we can agree to disagree
I don't believe in being able to agree
to disagree on truth I think it's
important to understand it and and the
question I have here is like what could
be the danger in believing and teaching
this concept right here what God doesn't
send us truth to hurt us
or anything it's it's for our own good
so what could be the danger and not
knowing this truth and I think you
touched on a little bit that you're
thinking well I'm not gonna go through
that I've literally like had like I've
wanted to like study Revelation with
people I want to study who the Beast is
what the mark is and they say I don't
need to study that I'm not gonna be here
for that Wow whoa so so if you already
think that the devil he can't touch me
because I'm not gonna be around for this
delusion yet the Bible is pretty clear
this delusions coming and people that
aren't rooted in the foundation of that
truth I mean I would encourage any
viewer even if you have the the
perspective of the rapture look into
this study this we're gonna have a
downloadable study guide but this is
right you know a little study got in the
tree about this second coming
I guess along with what you're saying is
Jesus said over and over again in
Matthew 24 do not be deceived do not be
deceived do not be deceived he was
talking to his own people right and in
other words all these things are coming
at the end along with it is coming false
theology there wouldn't be any point
the saying do not be deceived if there
was nothing for us to be around to be
deceived yeah you want to be deceived
because you're gonna be gone right yeah
so Jesus is pretty clear yeah
deception is coming he didn't want us to
be deceived so we do need to be
concerned about it yeah sounds like the
same reason he only put remember on one
commandment and that commandment is what
see people to seem to be forgetting do
not teach do not break the least
commandment and don't teach others of
Wrigley's commandment hmm heaven will be
calling you the least if you do this is
why I think it's very important to
understand Christian history I mean I
think when you get back to the roots of
like the whole Protestant movement why
was Luther calling a particular
religious entity that beast power like
why why not understand those things
because if you're the Christian
denomination you're like whatever I
don't need to understand this because
it's just something that's gonna apply
to someone that's not me hmm that end
group of people are going to deal with a
religious you know is institution that
the devil is going to twist and and we
need to know what that is because it is
gonna be of a crazy deception it's
Satan's masterpiece that's right and so
I I feel like you know it's really
important to understand the concept of
the second coming when it is where it is
what does the Bible actually say about
this I really really encourage all the
listeners you guys seriously dive into
this even if you disagree with what
we're having to say take a look at these
verses and go through each one and
prayerfully ask for the Spirit of God
God show me the truth in this part this
spot show me the truth here because God
will not ignore us when we are literally
laying our hearts out to him going show
me the truth don't put on the mental
blinders and be like even if you've
grown up thinking these kind of things
stand on the Word of God stand on the
truth and let that be the rule I mean
because I mean what happens if the mark
of the beast comes and you're still here
you're not prepared you don't know what
to look for you don't even know what the
mark of the beast is because you didn't
step
okay and it says only the very elect
will not be deceived I was wondering if
anybody knew where this pre-tribulation
concept came from I I know that it
started like in eighteen hundreds or
something right it did many people kind
of pinpoint Darby John Darby as
originating the pre-tribulation rapture
theory where he got it from his subject
of debate in other people's minds but
the fact that Darby was publishing it
and teaching it it's pretty common
knowledge I think I read that he had
developed it as early as 1826 and then
after Darby there was a man named
Scofield and Scofield had his own Bible
and in Scofield it's Bible there were
notes like commentary notes you can
think of it like a Study Bible and that
actually sold millions and millions of
copies and so it's easy to see when
influential theologians had picked up on
this and then the Bible is distributed
this Bible is distributed with all these
notes how many people picked up on the
idea and through his commentary so one
thing we could do is talk about the
rebuttals I don't most people can't
rebuttal these verses and they really
don't well I don't know exactly the
verse but it's in there somewhere but
they'll say things like we are not
appointed unto God's wrath how do you
answer that we are not appointed bunch
of God's wrath yeah there's a Bible
verse I don't have a Bible app on what's
the context to that so this is supposed
to be proof that we're gonna be gone
before his wrath is poured out of it
mm-hm
first Castle onehans five so what do you
got there kidney for God hath not
appointed us to wrath but to obtain
salvation by our Lord Jesus Christ and
verse 10 says
who died for us that whether we wake or
sleep we should live together with him
so what do you think I mean I mean that
just to me right up there of a surface
is like that God didn't create you to
just you know burned Marin he's trying
to save you right and he's given you
every opportunity to be saved if you are
burned in the end it's because of your
choice not because of God's choice that
that's what that that means for wrong
that and I was thinking even before I
would think well that must mean we're
gonna be sucked off the earth it means
that when his wrath is poured out and
the bowls of Revelation that there were
gonna be sealed through that time he
tells us all right the Bible says to not
pour those plagues out until my servants
are sealed in their foreheads my
question is who are those servants that
are being sealed if we're not here hmm
the tribulation Saints who aren't even
Christians I mean these are people who
don't believe in God but they're through
the tribulation and they just refused
the mark of the beast are they really
called Saints and they're being sealed
yes foreheads I think another little
window into God's character too is that
you know he is not slack for the sake of
being slack he's he's literally patient
with humanity because he doesn't desire
any of us to be lost right so you know
why would he just be like well clock's
ticking dude y'all gonna learn you know
I mean he's gonna take his time if if he
could save you he would extend the time
and I think that the whole end of the
world of that the final moments are are
happening in the time because if God
extended that ten thousand more years
you're still not gonna choose him please
the point of me says I have this short
in the days or there'd be no flesh saved
I mean we'd destroy ourselves nuclear
bombs or whatever you know this is true
you know when when you guys see some of
our future documentaries coming out now
we're gonna discuss like AI and
transhuman and all that kind of stuff
you will see that we have opened
Pandora's box and
would literally destroy ourselves yes
time was allowed today's episode is
brought to you by a table in the
wilderness who made these awesome plant
base for the kingdom t-shirts and
they're promoting a very healthy
lifestyle I'm sure you have seen a lot
of companies jumping on board with this
plant base world so check them out Keith
tell us a little bit about them you know
healthy eating isn't cheap healthful
foods are not only expensive they're
inaccessible to the poor the majority of
places known as food deserts in Oklahoma
have high rates of diabetes heart
disease in certain types of cancers many
people are uneducated about how to eat
right and how food affects the body in
mind a table in the wilderness is
embarking on a long term effort to
educate Oklahomans on healthful living
providing plant-based foods to people
with limited access to it and reaching
people with the everlasting gospel you
can check them out
in the link below
[Music]
so just to kind of wrap things up and to
put some bullet points on it we know
that this has happened at the last
trumpet it's gonna happen when he's
going to send out his angels at the
harvest which is the end of the age at
the end of the earth and you gave some
good parallels about how the the
Israelites were in Egypt when the
plagues are poured out that's a perfect
parallel for us they went through ten
we're going to go through seven but
we're going to be preserved Jesus was
with shadow at Meshach and Abednego in
the fire
you know Noah was not pulled off the
earth and and in that situation the
destruction and his salvation happened
at the same time there wasn't seven
years of separation there so all the
examples we have of this happening was
the structure of the wicked and and
separation of gods you know God was
separating his people out of that
destruction but it wasn't pulling you
off the earth for seven years and we
don't see that anywhere in the Bible so
is there a rapture there is a rapture we
are caught up together in the clouds to
meet him but it's the second coming okay
so I should ask is there a rapture
separate from the second coming of Jesus
the second coming is the rapture I mean
right that's what I see who wants to do
some man-on-the-street there is there
was only one rapture of the second
coming changed my mind oh yeah the
second coming is the rapture change my
ignorance or a denial of something does
not prevent it from happening what what
I think is beautiful is is really the
Bible has multiple things that it really
spells out the bible does interpret
itself and if you really start to like
dive in and not just nitpick this is one
little verse here this one little verse
here it's like it will explain what
those things are I mean a simple example
like the one one guys here one guy's
gone I'm still on that whole like whoa
dude the birds are eating this flesh
like even that is a red flag the Bible
holds no contradiction so if there's one
verse that kind of seems out of place
from all these other verses maybe the
interpretation is
incorrect it should be reviewed we're
told to study line upon line here a
little there a little to study to show
your own self approve don't believe us
don't believe everything that comes from
behind the pulpit or Hollywood for sure
so let's just dig in our Bibles and
really find the truth if you guys want
to study this out more there is a link
in the download or there's a link in the
description for a download and free
download about the Second Coming and
we'd like to hear your comments if you
learned some of the day if you disagree
with what we're saying if you want to
give us the verse that proves the
pre-tribulation rapture we'd like to see
that we'd like to respond we love
communicating with you guys and if you'd
like to support this ministry you can do
so on patreon also don't forget to like
share and subscribe and share this with
friends that may be believing these
things we love you god bless you we'll
see you next Friday
[Music]